La querían bocabajo, con le culo en pompa, esposada, atada.
La querían sabiendo que ella nunca los querría.
Oh, la querían santa,
bautizada en su divinidad,
querían sus secretos,
margaritas para los cerdos.
Querían desenmarañar el misterio de su diseño.
Fascinados por la gloria, hipnotizados por su clase.
Oh, la querían completa.
La querían entera,
aunque ellos vinieron fraccionados, mitad corazón, mitad alma,
sin miramientos ni conocimientos sobre quién era de verdad.
Oh, pero si lo supieran.
Si la conocieran,
lloverían alabanzas en canciones de las nubes de sus ojos,
despejando la visión, bañando el corazón.
Harían reverencias cuando la vieran.
Darían lo mejor de sí a su alrededor.
Si la conocieran,
sabrían que era el pegamento de su revolución.
El curso de la vida de la sangre en sus venas.
Si la conocieran,
ella sabría,
ella sentiría,
que su cuerpo es más que el campo de batalla.
Más que el hueso roto y fanatismo sangriento.
Más que un puente sobre tu conciencia aquejada.
Más que gastado, andado, devorado y disparado.
Más que tu "Selma, Lord, Selma" Edmund Pettus.
Más que tu asesina: Katrina Danziger.
Más que tu fúgate de Baltimore "Highway to Nowhere".
Si la conocieran,
ella lo sabría.
(Cantando)
Mujeres salvajes,
mujeres salvajes, caminan con búfalos.
Tienen relámpagos en la lengua,
sacuden escobas como armas.
Las mujeres salvajes andan con machetes.
Con sabiduría, con elegancia, con calma.
Las mujeres salvajes tienen huracanes en el vientre,
que liberan inundaciones de enseñanzas.
Oh, las mujeres salvajes vuelan libres.
Observa sus caminos, sus rasgados jirones.
Oh, quién puede entenderla,
a ella que es el sinuoso río Níger
uno que no tiene miedo de atreverse
solo para vagar y convertirse en el viento mismo.
Ella que habla en ráfagas y ciclones
haciéndonos volar de vuelta a la tierra, alta conciencia,
se da la vuelta y el mundo también,
Siente como gira,
abarcando varias vidas.
Escúchala hablar, alarma chispeante.
Mírala bailar, invocando a la muerte,
resucitando nueva vida.
El cielo la escucha llamar a sus puertas,
transportando con cuidado a los que buscan su ayuda.
Las mujeres salvajes abren portales a mundos nuevos,
discursos nuevos, sueños nuevos.
Oh, queridos míos,
qué queridos fallecieron lejos de los caminos del que les guarda,
tengan cuidado.
Porque a las mujeres salvajes no se las puede dominar.
Tan solo admirar.
Déjala entrar y sé testigo de cómo quema tus días.
(Aclamación) (Aplausos)
Gracias.
(Aplausos)